ich bin drauf ist hier beim
österreichischen bundesheer mein verband
ist das aufklärungs artillerie bataillon
7 in feldbach wo ich als
aufklärungsquoten kommunen tätig
[Musik]
aufklärung praktischen erklärung
beinhaltet die aufklärung die braunen
aufklärung und die rhader aufklärung
[Musik]
die beobachtungsstelle wird mit
technischen und betrieben wobei
spiegelreflexkameras spektive werte der
computer zum einsatz kommen
unterstützt werden wir von drohnen
aufklärung und realer aufklärung
in einem gefäß stand findet planung und
führung stattfinden zum beispiel beweist
ausgaben start und während des einsatzes
laufen hier die informationen zu sammeln
auf der dann für uns entscheidungen
getroffen werden
[Musik]
die artillerie erstellt mit den
ausgewerteten daten der aufklärungs
truppe einen vorher unterstützungsplan
und stellt mit ihren hauptwaffensysteme
der band sowie weitreichende vor
unterstützung sichern
[Musik]